[Music]
[Applause]
hello everybody hello my name is Mark
Barnard --an I am Danny Fernandes and
this is another episode of black man
beyond hey how are you I'm good
so fat man beyond like yeah slash thick
Latina like how can I also be a part of
this brand oh we can make it up and we
can make it
okay so what is your recollection of the
first time that we met because I have a
different one well we met on Twitter
does that count sure but realize we
grabbed dinner at kitchen 24 mm-hmm okay
it's not I remember it yeah
no well please tell me when I worked at
Playboy at the Playboy comm I was the
the culture at her entertainment center
or whatever it was and and we through a
Comedy Hour
oh yes yes it's a song hey there we go
we are you know we're [ __ ] Playboy we
had this awesome office and video
equipment well like why don't we do like
a comedy showcase and and one of my
colleagues decided to like just wrap her
arms around it and set it up and you
were one of the performers that's a you
know as so funny as I came in and when I
do stand-up I'm just wearing like a
hoodie and converse and you show up to
Playboy and there's all these playmates
and they're like everything snatched and
the boobs are not the size of mine and I
show up at the front door and they look
at me and they're like oh she's one of
the performers you know they they hooked
me up with drinks so you know some days
that's all you need
oh you can get so for the people at the
homes who aren't intimately familiar
with the things that you do why don't
you just tell us who you are where are
you from what you're all about where I'm
from kind of from all over did you know
that about me
I didn't I'm from I went to high school
Frisco Texas home of the fightin
raccoons I went to but my family is from
San Diego they moved us there because
they hated us when I was like 13
it's not even Dallas proper it's like
outside of I'm sorry Frisco if you're
watching also not even on the Wikipedia
okay so if you go to Frisco High School
Wikipedia this is gonna be my rant you
could if you go to Frisco High School's
Wikipedia the only notable alumni is a
dude who played one game of MLB baseball
one game it was like his first ever game
was May 10th
and his last game was May 10th it was
like just one single game in there yeah
do you like right back to you alumni
magazine I'm like [ __ ] do you
not know well people people will be like
just add yourself I'm like no I have too
much pride to add myself like I don't
know
someone else please add me uh things
where you have seen me III wrote in a
book called the good immigrant which was
really cool it's a collection of essays
from actors and writers of color I also
got to play myself and Ralph breaks the
internet which was really cool I was
made into a Disney character because I
host at Nerdist and geek and sundry and
I've been on sci-fi and all those things
so I posted all over the Internet
and Disney and E and so they made me
into me and you are also if I'm not
mistaken a fancy-ass writer yeah I'm
writing on a Netflix show called girls
on the bus which will come out in 2020
2021 2021 and then I also just sold a
show to HBO max about my life thank you
Oh fancy
Roy Wood jr. who's from The Daily Show
and Comedy Central he is producing it
really cool really dope Wow
I'm excited all right am i absolutely
not like facetious at all but did we
actually meet at Playboy we did in
passing I remember you came up and said
like one of us remembers having met you
and the other one is like we had brunch
once that I initiated you actually came
up to me and said hi I'm
Bernard --n i was introduced to you so
how this is Danny I said hey Danny how
are you I run the website like oh cool
that sounds like something nice okay one
of my favorite my one of my best friends
was the producer of gene Simmons Family
Jewels right my friend Adam and
consequently I have met gene Simmons
like four or five times which is [ __ ]
weird and random and insane but I got to
go backstage when kiss was playing
Madison Square Garden which is
ridiculous because it's like [ __ ]
Rock Valhalla and here are the oldest
titans in the business and they're
[ __ ] like all strapped in they're
like demon gear and whatever and they're
doing a meet-and-greet and one dude
comes up to gene Simmons and goes hey
gene I don't know if you remember but I
met you like four years ago in Akron
Ohio and gene looks at him straight in
the face not even a smile and he says if
you had my life would you remember you
like his ancestors felt that like oh
Jesus I'm good oh well you know I'm dead
now goodbye and so sometimes I feel that
way about myself I wouldn't remember me
I had to perform you know what I'm doing
before that would it be like going over
my set list and being like a my sweaty
and can I remember the joke about my mom
like I don't know again I'm sorry I
blame nobody for nothing because in that
situation where they're like playmates
everywhere and open bar and pressure I
wouldn't remember me either but I did
reach out to you and I said hey friend
from Twitter
will you go to kitchen 24 with me which
is also cursed I've taken all this is
good I've taken like boyfriends there
and we all of the relationships and at
kitchen 24 it will be like fighting
about something there
well I'm now honored to have survived
you have so far nicely made it to the
kitchen - what are you really nervous I
never want to go back there again no age
or drink afterwards do not take your
loved one good ringing endorsement
kitchen 24 don't bring anybody you did
something together we were both on the
CW together yeah the crisis yeah so many
people wrote me about that I know that
was so weird and random it's the like
Heather's doing a thing and it's like
hey you know would be awesome if you
brought mark - and I'm like yeah it
would bring me and pay me some money you
just wanted to see the crisis episodes
are the roughest [ __ ] cuts y'all
don't know but with what they edit out
like what we saw every time they move
you can hear the rubber like just and
it's just like it was so previous as a
bunch of dudes like on a set punching
nothing and like swinging bows at empty
[ __ ] and it's like I know this will be
great once they put in the bad guys and
the music and the drama but uh but yeah
so we did that which was super fun you
refereed the trivia game that I'm pretty
sure that I won I'm pretty sure you did
I was rigged for Kevin to win because I
get it yeah like he's your [ __ ] host
you're not gonna truck him in from Akron
Ohio or wherever he was on tour to be
like you lost trivia I think you did win
yeah I [ __ ] killed it I'm just saying
that's just for reddit to know just
between us girls 400,000 people yeah on
reddit I I've been watching some [ __ ] on
the televisions and the Internet's did
you know okay first did you watch the
Super Bowl at all I did did you watch
the commercials of the Super Bowl
I was yeah you kind of have to yeah did
you also make everybody in your house
shut up when the the Falcon and Winter
Soldier came on this but you know yes
and yeah totally awesome yes and no
because I knew I'd be seeing it
everywhere like the next year hmm
so yeah it was funny though the person I
was with Mark Ellis who we both know
who's
really funny yeah great guy super great
guy except if you're trying to ask a
question during the Top Gun trailer and
that he's not a nice guy I was like I
have not been paying attention so I was
like oh is Tom Cruise in this and can
you just can you just I just want to
listen to this it's only 30 seconds
I was super excited when like oh hey is
that cap shield what's cap she'll do is
that winter soldier all my come on
division looks wild and I'm here for it
yeah I I was specifically here for the
means that like the Dolly Parton
challenge with one division in it
he's like Scarlet Witch don't elite in
there and just say but and did we get
anything from Loki or was it just like a
shot of his face going like I missed a
little stand yeah basically although I'm
super excited about the Owen Wilson news
what we'll get there I'm a little less
excited just cuz I wanna Bowl something
white whatever take all the risks I'm
here don't worry have you seen any of
Star Trek Picard I haven't yet I'm
pronouncing it wrong I know it's about
Picard
hi-hi-hi card hard I'm kind of diggin it
not necessarily because it's good but
because it's Picard
you know it's scratching all those
nostalgia things for me words this was
my first tour track the first Star Trek
show that I actually watched a lot of
and it's that guy and I saw him on a set
once in the outfit and it's everything
and he wouldn't let me sit in his chair
and that was weird
every day that story that sounds about
normal yeah when I was in I was an
intern on Star Trek in my junior between
the summer between my junior and senior
years of college and and so I was like
reading scripts and sitting in on pitch
meetings and I was you know the schmuck
kid who's a college student man didn't
see some stuff but then they gave us a
tour of the enterprise set and I'm again
like 20 years old like losing my [ __ ]
mind
and I wanted to sit in the chair and get
a picture taken because I had seen
pictures of that like this is
pre-internet so it's like I had seen
pictures of that like fanzines and [ __ ]
like well I want to sit in the [ __ ]
the throne and when I got there the
publicist was walking around said well
mr. Stewart is very protective of that
chair for him Star Trek is like
Shakespeare and that chair the captain's
chair is his throne so he really doesn't
like people to sit in it I was like but
I just can I listen like just watching
me crest fall free fall into a crest and
and so I just like sad [ __ ] like
Charlie Brown's my way off the sack in
the corner they've been shooting this
episode
it's called relics I think and it's
where Scotty comes back to the to the
next generation and he goes in the
holodeck and he builds the original Star
Trek bridge he's super nostalgic it's
like I want the bridge of the enterprise
no bloody a door bloody be noble ADC and
so they had built that set so there was
like one third of the classic Star Trek
bridge sitting there and Captain [ __ ]
Kirk's chair is there and I'm like I'm
gonna sit in that [ __ ] Wow i'ma sit in
it almost fart in it I'm like working
ass groove in it just like you have your
chair Ida floured that one over there
but they didn't invite me back I'm gonna
do like 20 squats swamp-ass I called my
manager I'm like hey can you get me a
job on Star Trek my car's like no
because of what you did they still
remember remember this man just a
picture of your ass the grooves left on
my ass we got the Kirk's chair that's
I'm kind of digging it it's uh it's
[ __ ] Patrick Stewart at like 80 years
old still running kinda still jumping
kinda but he's awesome the show I think
has potential
are you watching anything that you like
yeah I'm watching The Outsider on HBO I
don't know if anyone else has watched it
it's spooky it like
gets all of my boxes it tingles all the
right places for me I mean I watch it
when it was Castle Rock I'm not I'm just
saying yeah I love it it's I think Jason
Bateman he's any but he also directed I
think several of the episodes
directly the first two the first two
yeah which are the ones that he's in and
I I have also seen it and I also like it
even though I'm kind of I'm a little
ahead of it I think I kind of think I
know what the thing is that the thing is
I'm not gonna spoil it for you people
because you should watch it it's
actually pretty well done and it's
Stephen King so it's like really
interesting character study and then
crazy [ __ ] supernatural thing yeah
trapped in the middle of it the only
thing that was weird in it is somebody
mentioned a doppelganger and they're
like that's like a person that kind of
looks like you and I was like how does
people not network No
HBO is like people just what is this
where people are not gonna know dot
double people are not gonna do example
it's not a weather thing is that like a
Doppler 4000 thing did you have dopplers
in the west coast or the south coast we
grew up no it was like the [ __ ] arms
race in New York and the East Coast cuz
they're all about the [ __ ] weather
right there's storms and hurricanes and
Nor'easters whatever and it was the
weird channel for WBC and we got the
Doppler 4000 weather radar and then like
CBS was like [ __ ] you we got the Doppler
eight thousand [ __ ] and then suddenly
became this like they were it was like
you know the US and Russia in the Cold
War it's like oh we got the doppler
12,000 we got three dopplers and they're
all 8,000 so but just tell me what it's
gonna be out I don't care it's a little
bit like the the razor wars where's that
gonna we got three blades on this razor
did you really [ __ ] you Gillette five
razors but why do you need fun because
we could fit five that reminds me of the
phone Wars where it's like our phone is
bigger and then it's like actually
people don't want big phones they want
something they can actually fit in their
pockets like our phone is smaller
nevermind
ours flips open they don't want it to
open I always doesn't I am still just
waiting I the phone that I want and I
don't know why the [ __ ] were talking
about phones but let's do this I still
want the matrix phone I don't think any
phone has been quite as cool that's
right like I mean yes I have the
complete storehouse of all human
knowledge in my pocket now
but I just want a thing where if I press
the button it goes good yes I talk to it
I just wanted to be cool to use I'm one
of those weird people that don't mind if
I get microchipped because at the
grocery store you'd still want to take I
you know I would this person all this
stuff I just want a microchip on my
wrist that I just like yep that's me
give me my stuff that's very
pro-government that's a little big
brother I hate people get so mad when I
say that it's like you know they're
looking at what you're watching I'm like
I hope they enjoy it I do I'm not I'm
not a fetish a mean I'm proud I'm proud
of my kinks I'm just always a little
weirded out when like I search for you
know anything on the internet and
suddenly there's an ad in my feed for
that very thing there's like oh man I'd
love to go to vacation at like some
Civil War [ __ ] Memorial battleground
and suddenly it's like do you like to be
a racist I'm like wait hold on
I don't want to Trumpy bear what code
words that I use I think this is not I
looked up like can a psychic know if
you've killed someone oh [ __ ]
I just wanted to know I mean like bail
bondsman's are up in your ads like you
clearly killed a person you might need
some help I don't even know how we got
here no I don't care really one last
thing and only because I saw it and
loved it and so a little too late and
had middle talked about it before but
are you a Doctor Who fan I need to I
need you know I'm huge in the anime
world and I feel like I need to move
over I mean I literally have Goku and
Vegeta tattooed on me and there's a mic
here oh I'm just distracting this and
there's a my hero premiere in like a
week or two but anyways I need to like
I'm so into anime that I need to come
back into your space Doctor Who is the
long I will say that I am NOT like the
craziest Doctor Who fan I'm a casual
Doctor Who fan the thing I like about it
it's an anthology more often than not
where it's hey what's happening this
week
brand new [ __ ] advantage with brand
new [ __ ] characters and you
during her companions drop in and they
do some [ __ ] it's like scooby Doo really
but with more lasers but the most not
the most the second two most recent
episode they introduced a previous
iteration of the Doctor Who if you're
not clear like he every time regenerates
every time so no some bad should happen
new body new face what and it's like
just it's like a bond thing we can just
restart with an actor again but they and
and there's been a very specific
timeline of like who's been a doctor how
many doctors are there I'm a Ninth
Doctor person well I'm a Seventh Doctor
person they introduced a doctor that we
hadn't heard of before who was a black
woman and it was fascinating and lovely
and wonderful and you know it's I
struggle occasionally with the the term
that I get thrown a lot forced diversity
people are unhappy with new things and
they're all things chocolate in the
vanilla we just hate that it looks like
the how the world actually looks we
don't want to do that it must be as it
ever was
but for Doctor Who of all shows which
not for nothing has had the ability to
be able to have done this before and
hasn't to finally reckon with itself
casting Jodie Whittaker as the first
female doctor was a big deal but now
even introducing the idea that oh hey
you know the doctor could technically
look like anybody and still kind of be
the same person and isn't that cool if
suddenly that person is just a person
who looks a little different but they do
all the things you love and they like
all the things you like the Internet has
had its feelings about it as either has
feelings about lots of things but I
chose to screen that part of the
internet out and just kind of relish in
the people feeling seen for the first
day yeah I totally loved this thing
since their grandparents showed it to
them on PBS and black and white reruns
that are now 40 years later getting to
see themselves in a real way that always
just warms my heart yeah and and it was
also a really good episode like
especially if you don't know what's
gonna happen I'm sorry I [ __ ] spoil it
but if you don't know what's happening
going in and you just let it on spool
for you it's it's it's just a really
good episode of TV that happens to
like kind of progressive and lovely and
well you were on the James Bond episode
of my show no deficit and we talked
about that too cuz they were like
there's no way and we were just saying
like technically that moniker can go to
anyone and it's like the guy like this
guy's getting you know older he can't be
as James Bond Z as he wants to be like a
jersey that they retire it's like no one
else can be double-oh-seven goes up
there yeah and they're playing with that
I think in the new movie no time to die
where where I think yes Lynch is playing
double-oh-seven
yeah she's not James Bond right
double-oh-seven and and that's awesome
like why isn't that a thing that we just
see getting passed down to anybody who's
really good at this job also they're
gonna run out of numbers like just yeah
it's a bad numbering system because it's
really only like one zero one one zero
that doesn't sound cool at all until you
get to like agent triple six yeah that
is cool again
but everybody between until you get to
whatever agent it spell spells boobies
in the calculator it's 56 upside down I
was in high school I had a calculator no
see I had boobs in high school so I
didn't have to do no I was obsessed in
ways that couldn't exercise themselves
beyond calculator tricks oh boy
one of these days I don't have to turn
anything upside down to Z boobs
meanwhile I was like wow these are fun
when did these come around
I had heard reports were wild and varied
but they all were very specific on that
front you know we have guests here yeah
I feel like we've soiled the front rug
and now they've got to come into this
house and like we got to make nice but
we will do that because both of these
guests independently and together mean
quite a bit to me because when I first
moved to LA seven years ago I was alone
like my family was still back east I was
out here for six months on her TV gig
and I didn't really know anybody had one
four
here but everything everything else
about this time was alien to me and then
my friend Shana Benson who I only knew
from the internet she little emails I
was like what are you doing this
Saturday night it was like [ __ ]
nothing I don't know anybody she's like
you've got to come with me to this
things like what is it's called a
thrilling adventure hour and I was like
oh [ __ ]
I don't know what that is but it sounds
cool and I went and it was amazing it
was if you're not familiar with it it
was a long-running monthly show that
went for something like 12 years in LA
in one location they moved to Largo at
the Coronet and it was an old timey
radio show where a bunch of actors would
come out and stand there in suits and
ties in front of mics and they would
tell three different stories it was like
the old mercury theater with Orson
Welles the Mercury Theater today we're
gonna do blah and and one of the the the
steady streams of it was Sparks Nevada
who was the sheriff on Mars and I always
loved you just tuning in literally
tuning in once a month to the new
adventures of this character and that
and the work juice players well the
actors involved and the rotating cast
would come in would be amazing and and
that show is very much the fault of at
least two of the people that are about
to come up here today one of them is Ben
blacker who was a TV writer and a
podcaster and the co-creator that filled
like amateur hour and the other one is
markovin Jackson whose amazing for lots
of different reasons not the least of
which is he spells his first name with a
C as all good marks dude he's a cult
it's a cult yeah and we get the best
jackets so yes without further ado
welcome to Ben blacker and Mark Evans hi
hi hey guys stay over there okay no be
over between us for a reason I feel like
we're here to renew our license what
number yeah yeah another weight is about
like 45 minutes I think did you make an
appointment I should have and I should
have brought a book II
while I'm reading the snow in church I'm
reading the snow in charity
thank you very much I gave the the
shitty quick and dirty version of the
thrilling adventure hour
it's my thrilling event our origin story
what is it for you guys well yeah
this was hi my name is Ben blacker
blocker
I am NOT on the good place or Brooklyn
nine-nine or anything you've seen the
thrilling adventure hour was as you said
a stage show did you just turn to me for
help it's yours
it was a stage show in the style of
old-time radio that we did for yeah 11
plus years at Largo at the Coronet it
was also a podcast and remains a podcast
people can listen to those it was our
job for 11 years it was the thing we did
every month my writing partner Ben Acker
and I wrote a new 80 page script every
month for a decade mark and other
incredible actors such as Paul of
Tompkins and paget Brewster and Busy
Philipps Josh Malina would star in these
genre comedy stories that we put
together and we were lucky enough that
you know cool people found it well how
did y'all meet like when what was there
was a research I was a recast deal it's
been 15 years
bogans Osborne first plates parked about
a you know read-through I think yeah and
you killed him Osborne was the he's the
dad in every 90s movie he was in that
thing you do and what's wrong with the
scary rabbit Donnie Darko night of the
Lepus okay yeah sure so Holmes did this
read-through and his Sparks was a very
laconic very Gary Cooper type just how
it was written I feel like right yeah
those early scripts definitely were that
and then I'm not capable of that yeah so
I made Sparks Nevada dumb guy with a big
ego and which is my sweet spot and and
then well years happened and you know
yeah
now we're blink of an eye 12 years
happen where when you guys are in the
world what is the thing that they and
you know for you especially and for you
definitely what is the thing they
recognize you the most from when I'm in
the world did you begin the question
when with the words when you guys are in
the world yes I did
Don LaFontaine we I was I was recently
out of town with my wife and I were out
with Mark and his wife I mean out of
town yeah
we're not always here but but being away
from Hollywood where people like are a
little weirder about recognizing people
like we're out in the world and Mark we
get recognized and you can sort of tell
as someone is approaching him what they
recognized him from talked about that
but it's true yeah like I can feel in a
room like if I'm having a good day and
care to talk to people I know where to
go and if I like I'm having a terrible
day and would like to be alone it's like
oh those people would have no idea who I
am like yeah you can tell the fandoms of
even within the like fairly microscopic
iterations of parks and recreation the
good place Brooklyn Brooklyn nine-nine I
know what I'm on we only have 15 minutes
yeah I was told Rick Baker win an hour
dude we can get a stool for you just
lean back
please yeah Baker get a stool he did cuz
he's 112 years
by the way a brief sidebar why I have
been making a joke that my DJ name is DJ
Rick Baker which my wife keeps telling
me to stop doing but I tell her it's
good because of my monster beats come on
[Laughter]
never said it publicly and I'm not sorry
please I'm not sorry you're wrong not to
be no that's a problem that is not my
new favorite thing I thought you would
like I'm going to steal it and I'll give
you credit for it when I'm out down
world
like guys I'm about to tell you the
whitest joke mark well which do you have
one in particular that you get the most
or in certain areas of the country I
mean is Kong Skull Island
I mean it you're joking that does happen
very deeply about the land set program
I mean like just because of where we are
currently it's um it's probably equal
parts Brooklyn nine-nine the good place
and and thrilling adventure hour but I
can all the way to like a different walk
it's like a muppet walk there's a look
in their eyes where they're like I know
that's Shawn I know he's a bad guy
I was in the drive-thru century he's
like like the rest of I was in it I was
in the drive-through in and in and out
and basically my neighborhood and I
could tell when I went to give the
person my card like it was like mm-hmm
they get it and and then it was like my
whole brain went like Kevin Costner
Brooklynite
and the kid 100% was like are you Kevin
Costner from Brooklyn and the answer is
yes it's great people love the stuff
they love people will come up to me and
be like Gina Gina Rodriguez I'm like yes
can I get a drink yes please bottle
service yeah thank you
charge it to the Underhill I don't tip
when I worked at Entertainment Weekly we
had a first staff retreat and there and
we were like that kind of meeting each
other and going away and like being kind
of grown-up kids and the seating charts
were all by like your celebrity
doppelganger and so like I get to this
[ __ ] giant table of all these faces
and I'm like listen there's like two
black employees one of us is gonna be
Denzel and one of us is gonna be blair
Underwood because why would you not do
that and I'm looking I'm looking I'm
looking at my [ __ ] and it was
Tracy Morgan and I was like couldn't you
just glow me up a little bit like
[ __ ] Billy Dee Williams is sitting
right there Marc what year though this
was like free limo crash yeah this was
like naked with a lightsaber you know in
fairness you could be naked with a
lightsaber I've been making if anyone in
this room we're going to be naked with a
lightsaber we'll Smitty Portier and then
there's Morgan and yeah sure I'd see how
you feel can I tell you a Hollywood
[ __ ] story please do so I the I play
the red herring in the movie 22 Jump
Street I played that person that you
think is the bad guy that turns out not
to be the bad guy it's Jillian Bello
spoilers still good still worth teams
door thing and
Phil Lord and Chris Miller directed that
movie and they are wonderful comedy
people and and improv people and so we
got on set I was playing a philosophy or
a psychology professor at on this movie
and I said the word in the script was
the word impression at one point and
they were like okay cool and it cut
between scenes they were like coca-cola
so next time next time you say the word
impression goes speaking of impressions
and then do an impression okay roll
camera all the way on and I think it's
by virtue of the thrilling adventure
hour of the John DiMaggio bender from
every voice in every way all the time
and then like he had been doing a Tracy
Morgan impression poorly for years that
was top of mind and so I was a
psychology professor at this fictitious
Southern University and they did this to
me they pimped me to go and do an
impression and I was like well this will
be racism great and so I was like
speaking of impressions and I said y'all
like psychology just as a finance in
Tracy Morgan I've been the shower the
morning of the premier wedding to go to
the premiere for that movie and I was
like what's going on in the world right
now and I was like oh uh 36 hours ago
Tracy Morgan was in a near-fatal like a
fatal limousine crash that's familiar
somehow
wait I didn't just like improvise a line
about him in a movie that's about to
debut tonight oh [ __ ] I did and I texted
fill in Chris I was like that that like
was one of a billion things we did that
certainly didn't inmate make the movie
and they were like you know we did it
all the way dead it's in the movie we
taking it out of the premiere tonight
because it's too soon we'll be in the
movie forever and it was horrifying and
just the way the universe works yeah
yeah
so it's also any impression that Jackson
does of some don't like psychology they
immediately get into a car or is this
every impression that impression like
Charlton Heston roll like psycho like
use it for good okay so then you you you
emailed me a mess in an hour
what are you Rick Picard what are you
watching these days
sunrise sunset you've got an audible
series it's an audible original most
tell me about Sarah audible original
this is a show called cut and run it's a
audible original you can get it on
audible you can also book just buy it
it's about best friends who are kidney
thieves and the havoc that wreaks on
their love lives their respective love
lives
the tale is all this time this is the
thing that Acker and I wrote in 2007 and
it's just sort of been kicking around
since then and then audible picked it up
a few years ago the cast is bonkers
tell me about two kind of stupid yeah
the scary I was with a lot of them last
night it's kind of dumb yeah we had like
a little premiere an improv show last
night and our leads are Darcy Cardin
from the good plays who is a gift she is
incredible
like to live with something take a break
to live with something for over a decade
and like the weight of casting that
thing and having the right people in it
we got so lucky with Darcy especially
but also like the whole cast Sam
Richardson plays her best friend and
partner Rachel bloom plays his love
interest Thomas Lennon plays her love
interest
they're only in it because they're all
my friends did you get your like five
days we really helped her format
double text no he helped us cast Darcy
and Eugene Cordero who plays a wormy
dude who's so funny the narrator of this
show is meg Ryan what yeah
from everything you've ever loved okay
does does she actually show up in like a
robe and slippers all the time which is
just sound that way she out legitimately
she recorded in her home in Martha's
Vineyard so she was very comfortable but
she what so my writing partner's name
has been Acker my name is Ben blacker we
know and we've heard it for fifteen
years we've been working together but
then meg Ryan says you're listening to
an audible original this is cut and run
by Ben a core and Ben blacker and gives
this laugh and it's the best thing
that's ever so anyway it's out there go
to audible.com slash guy Riley jr. Ed
Begley Jr the cast is bonkers
I would that because i retweeted your
announcement tweet and then I get the
notification that Ed Begley Jr likes
your tweet what the [ __ ] is happening
here these are worlds that are never
supposed to collide and Begley Jr plays
he plays the nicest crime lord in the
midwest that was the role that we were
looking for and we're like it has to be
at Begley Jr I was gonna say meanwhile
meg Ryan followed me on insta nice
things about me so I might be done yeah
this might be it the sweetest guy he
would he was recording in the booth with
Rachel and Sam and he you know like he's
been doing this for 40 years and he's
still incredible but he left and was
like I have to go now I'm sorry I have
to go to a shoot you all are wonderful I
love what you are doing it's perfect I'm
sorry for slowing us down I have to
like so sweet and does he just give out
electric cars you get a car we were
afraid to print a scrip for him
certainly he doesn't want a printed
script we have it digitally for Ed
Begley Jr the greenest man on earth
you can write up a screen in this iPad
we don't care he printed his script
really like you wouldn't the good place
just wrapped up like habit what I mean
did you still got a call time what good
place mark in the last episode of the
good plays yeah I'm trying to break it
to you you do something I had never seen
you do I haven't I didn't get to tell
you this when I saw you last night there
was a bit where I think you are like
pretending to not like something was
that in the last episode or maybe the
penultimate episode I don't know you
shot it months ago
sure but he he does this he has this
moment where you don't exactly look at
the camera but you kind of side eye to
see if anyone sees that you I had not
seen it before it was a versatile lovely
piece of acting
I'm malleable and versatile falls
[Music]
through then I get uncomfortable with it
you got uncomfortable but yeah that's it
that was it
do you mind if I ask a few questions by
all means sir thank you is the good
place as it's over was it as terrible to
shoot as it seems like it was yeah just
like egos
kidding aside the good place was the
good place the good place just about any
Mike Schur joint is like the very best
workplace you could ever hope for and
everyone that's there cares about what
you're doing and they're good at it
they're at the top of their game there's
no like they literally could come in
moments before you roll on this podcast
or whatever is happening right now we
just hit a bar man just in a bar I mean
normal normally I'd have a full time ago
you 100% could and I mean this factually
they could go guys we're about to go
this is all great what you've done is
great
we were wrong the whole thing needs to
be over here 180 degrees and nobody goes
[ __ ] what nobody they go okay hey
guys come on we're gonna move this we're
gonna clock it around like everybody is
like so skilled and so accomplished and
wonderful and that's the good news of it
the bad news of it is that as soon as
you realize that that's possible in life
Oh everything you else you experience
like like you realize like oh we have to
be aiming for this Mike Schur has a no
jerks rule so on set cast crew anywhere
top to bottom above the line below the
line there's nobody that's like
obstreperous or problematic or ego
driven or whatever like everybody just
wants to be good they're all working in
that direction
99% of the time like unacknowledged ly
like they're like it's just people that
are doing their jobs and maybe 1/8 of
something I'll make the frame and
somebody to go was that Joe was that a
joke and people go yeah and I like so
much of it doesn't make the screen and
but everybody in the world wants to be
great
and maybe let's do that from now yeah it
seems like a good way to make you sir
are you ready that is what I would mark
Evan Jackson 2027 we are right on yeah
yeah I mean you won the Iowa caucus did
you did you steal anything from the set
Steele's a weird word just their hearts
right you liberate anything did you set
something free from the set I own
what about every cent every bit I'm
keenly aware of the value of items so
steal is a strange way to frame anything
yes I do own a lot of screen-used
remember the most recent of which the
list is too long
I will tell you two things one I was
just I just I hosted the official
podcast for the NBC's the good place and
while recording the penultimate episode
there did happen to be a bit of graphic
art that was used on screen they come to
me in the good place and the you know
the OG good place on the universal back
lot and I'm smashing crystal figurines
at one point and it's the greatest
everyone in character this was for the
show it's not so it's the very best and
these were not legitimately crystal but
they were a heavy-ass lucite and I
smashed about 40 nice things and you
should it's the greatest but I was
smashing like figurines from a cart
called Joanie Loves Chachi keys Wow
so maybe Megan and Ram Jam hypothetic
monster beats there might be a sign in
my office right now it at the home where
I lived that says joining also they were
like and this is a deep cut
you watched NBC's the good place but
they were like oh you can take that if
you want and it's a seven-foot-tall
kiosk in which Matt from accounting like
Heinz to evaluate the afterlife
experiment for I don't know it looks
like a like a porta potti
it was once referred to in a script as
Darth Vader's Wang so yeah this is the
right crap yeah this is uh yeah yes they
were
I have not arranged shipment yet but I
will be taking that like the security's
like eyeing your car as you didn't love
the lot like he's riding low he's riding
low what's in the trunk yeah have we
beat Rick Baker you know I think you
know you've made him proud sorry I'm
just thank you Dana Brown thank you
because he's like eight Oscars you know
so not quite yet what is what is next
for both of you guys what are you more
Brooklyn nine-nine
okay sure okay I put in a call so yeah
that's gonna happen is it all secret
deep NDA I mean there is stuff that's
secret but
oh this has not been anounced scoop this
is whatever this is this is like the
first time I took him to comic-con no
joke he was walk around like I may just
wear these costumes Netflix is doing a
series based on the books called the
baby-sitters club and and you are one
more baby sitters one of the
babysitter's Claudia I play all the
young girls this yeah I play all the
twelve-year-old multi-cultural it's a
yes range it's a bold new take let's
presume I play somebody's father and
it's about it's gonna drop in the next
few months and it's exciting it's a it's
a wonderful take on important material
and it's culturally great like this
inclusive and wonderful and I'm so proud
of it it's awesome what about you mr.
black er um you know a whole bunch of
things I can't talk about as you know
but you know Acker and I spent 10 years
trying to get cut and run made as a
series and it was originally written as
a TV show so now that it's an audio
series maybe someone will want to make
it as a TV show what so that's something
we won't until two weeks from now what
luck you can you can have it right now
that's awesome listen gentlemen I cannot
thank you enough for spending your
hard-earned Tuesday night here in a nerd
bar in Hollywood whatever this is
whatever whatever we always thank you
what I love this show thank you guys
[Applause]
well holy crap that was super [ __ ]
fun I learned a lot of things as I mean
I learned like every other thing that
you can steal from NBC and that's all it
takes
oh okay awesome
we got postcards thank you we're gonna
make it rain I wanted to ask the kidney
stealing was this inspired you never
know my shows inspired by my life so I
never you never know you never can tell
I think we should talk about some news
let's do it let's [ __ ] do it
this is the part of the show where as
Kevin likes to say I looked at the
internet and press copy and paste and
stole it all and now I'll just read it
to you because I'm providing a service
there yes
that the internet doesn't provide yeah
no I'm just I'm now reading it that's
the thing you don't have to do you don't
have to read your like your own audible
free [ __ ] that people probably already
know today maybe you don't know this
because it was just announced today
Disney in a big stockholder call where
they tout their games and their revenue
and whatever whatever they dropped at
the mandalorian season two is coming in
October but my baby Yoda is coming in
March oh hell yeah
oh my god that man oof how well are we
the man the man Domo the one who was
y'all oh if I wasn't writing on the show
I'd be writing some spicy fanfiction
about that man he is so how are our
rated is this show is he fine girl and
and I'm like I know he can't take his
helmet off but that doesn't mean you
know mm-hmm I saw that Widow sorry I
could talk about this forever I saw that
Widow and I was like she is willing to
risk it all and I was like everybody
wants to sit on this man
omit my god okay he's so fine I can't
Gina
oh my god I my by heart let me do I am
overwhelmed yes I'm sorry the
mandalorian not listen that's why we're
here because again you saw my news yeah
doesn't matter you saw my tweet let's do
this now ohh oh my god yes okay is it
the mandalorian himself or is it Pedro
Pascal in this I think it's all of it
okay the swag who has swagger in a suit
like that I mean come on what I will say
like sorry go ahead
no no I've had my piece I've said my say
on the mandalorian I'm Way more curious
about your essay he's he's just fine and
and like oh he just is commanding it's
very like BDSM I'm just gonna say say it
it's very all these gloves the kink
community was very felt good you know I
would I wouldn't have seen that coming
down the pike but I get it mm-hmm I mean
I was way more about Cara doom than I
was oh she's her too she can crush me
like a walnut yeah I said I was about to
say I just want them to adopt me but
that doesn't sound right
that doesn't sound I mean that is you
know that's it different that's a whole
different that's a whole different
category uh you got the search terms for
that yeah or a little bit bit
you know what I was saying like how they
say the NSA whatever is watching me and
I'm like you know I'm just I'm happy
that I gave some intern a boner like
let's get real here hey so now we get
more of it yes I'm excited which they've
already been shooting the roadman
filming season two so it's like for them
to drop it in October is not out of the
realm of possibility we're also getting
I think we knew that we were getting
Falcon in the Winter Soldier in August
and Wan Division in December a very
Disney Christmas I'm very a very
masturbatory Disney Christmas
like oh my well winter soldier were you
glad because everyone was so mad
I mean that's other fan fiction except
[ __ ] that the picture is out there yes I
mean it's not even know it was like
ghost well we're you mad a lot of people
were mad that the baby Oda
merch wasn't out in time for Christmas
but I was okay with the fact that Jon
Favreau didn't want it to be spoiled and
he like he was willing to take to make
Disney take the cut I mean that's that's
a baller [ __ ] right there
okay Disney you know what I want you to
do not make 100 million dollars yeah
cool yeah I guess but it's also like
every now and again I'm surprised at and
I guess awakened to the fact that you
can keep things secret if you want to
you know like when [ __ ] Netflix
decides oh yeah no we're dropping a
giant JJ Abrams movie right today yeah
or Beyonce is like hey have an album and
a movie and or whatever and we don't
know those things are happening that
there's no way for them to have like oh
no we're keeping this [ __ ] secret right
the minute we pull the plug
welcome to the stores everybody yeah
woosh that they can't do that surprising
well no but people were yeah but then
all the Thai place --is would have
access to it and you know like Marc in
accounting would would show it to his
girlfriend and then baby Oda would be
all over the place I mean that's a mark
with a k' mark mark with a cane every
important person in my life is named
mark I love it yeah but you know you
gotta watch the case okay too many of
them nobody wants to mini case no that
is accurate
yeah historically threes and nines bad
for K's historically historically bad
and and and Disney still not sure if the
mandalorian will go more than two
seasons I think that's all there that's
all they're wrestling with at the time
but they're talking about spinning it
off in two more seasons spinning
characters out of the mandalorian into
their own shows yeah who would you want
to see in their own show I mean kara
feel like yeah what did use ID 11 I want
baby oh
no I want Team Yoda yeah whatever
is this baby group right like this is
gonna do that [ __ ] ever what for that
dumb joke I kind of want I want whatever
the [ __ ] his name is called weathers
this character's name is mando would you
like a drink mando mando
I know your secret Creed and actually
that's lesson name and more like your
religion by saying Jew welcome to the
bar Jew whoa this got weird fast but
also we know his name and people still
call a mando feel like people are like
his name's not baby Yoda I'm like I'm
gonna call him that forever that's his
name I'm sorry I don't care if it's true
like I'm gonna call him it's Jeff with a
G Jeff the Yoda it has to be a why
there's yeah doll there's yeah I just
need it to be like Edie York - all right
I'm I'm I'm a Harbor sent on board for a
your Kara doom show being your bait teen
Yoda show happened got like posters of
like sexy girl Yoda's up and as well as
well so what are you doing in there
nothing I am yeah I'm touching it I
won't she's like going to the mall going
to topic hot oh he's all angsty yeah
where's your him smell this way smoking
not the green I am I need that tea
someone's gonna do it
they will you should do it I'll do it do
it don't even wait for pillow Walt I
know you're dead and you're like a
little bit racist but hey here's what I
want to do I'm sorry to me
mean to make it all about race except
that I did
speaking of race not at all
like Heath Stansfield transition you
know what I do that's I'm the master of
the sex speaking of black people look
Keith it's it's what I like to call the
incredibly obvious clunky Segway no I
love it
no it's great lakeil Stansfield one of
our finest young actors who you may have
seen in the sea uncut gems yeah knives
out and get out wants to play the Joker
yeah like are you excited I mean it'll
never happen but like yeah these are
these are my I definitely do I think
we've seen a lot of the Joker where I
would love if his take on someone else I
also wouldn't mind gender-bending and
having them be cat man like Batman and
cat man
it's 2020 like I'm ready for that
romance yeah and the title is like what
the Katmandu yeah ooh him in like tight
leather
I mean you I mean you said I could say
whatever I want and now I'm just like
well I love that one Ben and Mark were
here I was like oh I love your show it's
so great anyways the kink community it's
by the way we're mussing that helmet
[ __ ] I'm coming listen I'm down for
whatever the Keith wants to do like I
think he's a fascinating actor and the
his range is remarkable like he can go
from super sedate and super contained to
kind of [ __ ] crazy yeah which is why
I think the Joker didn't seem like it
was totally out of left field
totally I think you could kind of do
whatever he sets his mind on and
apparently he like dressed up as the
joke of a Halloween yeah and like made a
bunch of home movies of him as a joker
oh I want to see those for like my own
personal just academic curiosity just
know
he was really funny cuz he was like I
put the makeup on and then I was like
why don't I just not take this off look
man I don't have Sunday night's like
that i'ma dress up and just stay this
way I do I just want like I know we got
Joker but I want like a Lobo movie or
something you know I could just need
other other people in the rogue's
gallery I mean we shouldn't just keep
making joke of things I think I'd be
funny if we came out with like if we're
gonna do it commit to it and come out
with a new one every single year like
it's like you know for the fourth of
July
Christmas Joker day like we just need
one every single everyone gets their
chance at it when you're new to
Hollywood like you're an up-and-coming
director you get your Joker film we made
of like eight million dollars and it's
just sitting the room it's like really
angry about clowns other clowns bite in
his style it's just trying to poison
their reservoir [ __ ] keep
getting in my way
cube is the Joker Wow love it okay
goodbye Joker speaking of Joker's yes
Owen Wilson is joining the guys of Loki
Wow Wow whoa I'm sure he loves that well
it's his own [ __ ] fault
yeah did that for like a decade there
and made millions of dollars no hey we
make our own prisons it turns out okay
there's there's actually a video of Tom
Hiddleston doing an impression of have
you seen that Oh Owen Wilson as Loki
that's amazing hmm also scary that he's
a witch and like predicts things but I
mean dad to do the babes in the blood of
rabbits totally absolutely I see it he's
crying all kinds of [ __ ] in his basement
he's murdered innocent kids
Wow Wow sorry my drinking [ __ ] on my
drink
it's just redbull this is just you me
I'm tired and super so yes ready to
write my screenplay you heard it here
first boys and girls Tom Hiddleston
killed children babies are no blood in
the basement you're gonna get us this
video just won't exist nope the night
won't happen like something the lights
go out and like Kevin Feige standing
outside to shut it down I don't even do
a good Owen Wilson either I was thinking
of the impressions when the guys were
talking about impressions do you have
one that you do good I don't even hear
it's not no I can't do an impression at
all but I think I can okay and that's
even worse I have one of those too okay
what's your life mine is I do it all the
time on my podcast too actually Ben was
on there when I did it it's Jimmy
Stewart and it's a wonderful life yes
please
it's just um Clarence Clarence I want to
live Clarence
right Oh
Susan's petals Susan that's it and I do
this to show that he's like a feebly
cold old man that's right yeah that's it
you know I'm not even gonna try my
[ __ ] impersonations of like Idris
Elba because a the picture will not
match the voice and be it's just me like
kind of growling my voice pretending to
have like a [ __ ] canceling the
apocalypse that's all I got I don't love
it truly ya know and I feel like if you
close your eyes and turn on the TV with
a job on it I get there but independent
of that it's just me did you see cats
did I [ __ ] see cats by myself in a
theater in Simi Valley surrounded by
empty seats and this old couple there
and those two children and like two
o'clock on a weekday
I saw cats what I loved was that they
were what is it not anatomically correct
like they were not they well they have
boobs though but they didn't have the
downstairs no like the Barbie downstairs
it's a Barbie downstairs except Idris
they tried to hide it and I was like
Lord no they he won't you could see the
outline of the compression pants that
they tried to put on this man his
anaconda don't want none unless you got
buns hon like god bless you know like it
did he did all of it like that
motherfucker's patently unfair in almost
every way I'd once pitched when I was at
The Hollywood Reporter I'm gonna keep
telling stories about when I was a
journalist when I had purpose but I had
pitched a cover story on it just Alba
and my boss was like no that's really
great ideas on the cusp we should do it
do you want to interview him and I said
no because my fragile self-image cannot
withstand the hit of being in the same
room with that man and then having to
like go about the rest of my life
because we're the same age and like this
and that
are somehow in the same genetic world no
no I'll kill myself at the end of that
interview thanks adjust this has been
nice is that you going off a bridge God
okay here's the thing you should have
been in the same room cuz you could take
his essence there can be only one I feel
like he probably gives that off like
anyone who has been within it's like a
10-foot radius of him is just prettier
it's by law I mean I would have had to
[ __ ] him and probably would have because
Catman Batman I mean I'm just saying
2020 let's do it looking cat mount up on
his I been a cat so he's like he's all
about it just looking [ __ ] hmm
wearing that dumb hat because cats need
hats sure the sun's got us another but
he has little cuts like he cut the Hat
himself so his ears would stick out of
it yeah and he's wearing like a coat
because his coat isn't enough coat for
the sometimes they're naked sometimes
they're not
sometimes they're wearing the fur of
other cats around them yeah no that's a
Power Move yeah but I killed that cat I
would wear his clothes his skin
everywhere so you know what
odd here's the other cat under the cat
why I'm just gonna do that to my ex's
like yeah what now huh this was Kevin
he's not as warm as you'd think he'd be
yeah so uh Owen Wilson's gonna be in low
key next this one I think is going to
make you happy if it hasn't already
Netflix is making a one piece
live-action TV show yeah I know there
was a groan that was unnecessary audible
brought to you by audible fat groan was
i I know nothing about one piece mm-hmm
tell me about it
pirates okay
here's the thing if you're gonna do live
action because I think it's from the
same people doing Cowboy Bebop yes those
are live actionable animes like they
tried to make my anime Dragonball
Evolution it was rough
also Goku was white what happened
Hollywood but no further questions like
here's the thing Drac and I do think
that someone will a great director will
end up making DBZ live-action because
it's under I think the Disney everything
now and there's no way that you wouldn't
capitalize on something that has its own
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade balloon
so but these are more doable
especially for Netflix like they're more
grounded and it's like do these first
see how those feel and then do the the
space guys with the tails better
throwing fireballs then try that you
know I'm going to take your word for it
I think it's gonna be fine although some
of the some of the tits are just like
not like they're there I don't know
right they're gonna be hunched over I
don't even know how they're gonna do it
it's like comical tits they're just like
painfully big I'm sorry it's pornhub.com
comical comical yeah that's how some
some men draw tits that are so I see it
on deviantART and a tumblr Oh tumblr the
tits are so big they look painful like
did they look straining so anyways I
mean it's just like 90s comic book
covers but it's looked have you ever
seen there was some thing was a tumblr
but some artists drew male superheroes
the same way they draw female
superheroes and so like Wolverine was
like his ass was out to here but then
somehow was by like spina bifida just
cut back to spine so now he's up
straighten his boobs or like out to here
it's like like a Rob Liefeld drawing
basically yeah where and I got one sorry
Rob Liefeld you can't draw feet but yeah
and it was just written
Kilis the fact that this is how this is
what boys and the 90s were spanking
themselves - were these things that are
not reflected in reality in any way no
comical tits man comical painful tits it
feels like the name of a punk band but
yes I am excited for only because it's
tomorrow studios which again is doing
cow bleep Cowboy Bebop they've got some
like veteran riders Steven Maeda who did
loss in the x-files and Matt Owens who
was on agents of shield on the cage yeah
man I I'm excited for anything that
feels a little to the left of center and
comes from a place of love totally yeah
and occasionally painful appendages
there was a really great live action
rou-ha-nee Kenshin was if you haven't
seen it that's was very well done so one
of those favorites that one that one I
mean like of live action that's been
done well there's not we don't have too
many no most of them are done poorly
mm-hmm yeah there was a ghost in the
shell' that came out which is awful
there was a last airbender movie which
is yeah so not a great track record no
no wow it feels like there's a fight in
this booth over Death Note
so we're gonna move on past that and
speaking of which I have no segue to get
to pee-wee Herman but it's not about
[ __ ] PB Herman paul rubens wants to
make his dark peewee movie yeah no for
reals he he describes it as his valley
of the dolls we might be where he
describes it as House of a thousand
corpses peewee movies yeah you know
peewee emerges from prison to become an
unlikely yodeling star then moves to
Hollywood and becomes a movie star then
develops a severe pill and alcohol
addiction that turns him into a monster
it's about how did he get to prison
though we just glossed over that he was
killing dudes for Hiddleston that was
this guy okay
because you know nobody looks peewee
funny when he knocks at your door mm-hmm
you let him play with your kids right
it's about Fame Rubin says I don't know
whatever but he he wrote it like the 90s
and he couldn't get financing for it the
older that he's gotten the more afraid
that he was to do PB again because he
was making a Jedi battle he made like a
circus EP we face yeah on Netflix and
even then he was unhappy with the way he
looked on screen because I looked like
an old man even with all this makeup I'm
just not feeling it but then he sees the
irishman it's like oh we can do this
[ __ ] now yes I can do PB for another 20
years at this point and so apparently
he's approached the safty Bros who did
uncut gems yeah and and they haven't
said no the Kevin said yes but they
haven't said no and and he's a give me
15 minutes I will make the darkest
[ __ ] PB movie you can ever imagine
let's do a the question I have to ask is
does anybody want the dark yeah hell
yeah yeah yeah well know what one Scene
I've taken to describing introducing
most people the way Laurence Fishburne
introduces John wick John [ __ ]
wig and and I find that there's places
where you can do that and places you
can't yeah uh Church no not a good place
for that kind of like Oh have you met my
wife mocks [ __ ] why it's a
little weird yeah it's very Mendo like a
kid's graduation this is Billy [ __ ]
jr. no I think take all the risks take
all the risks I want to see all the
things and if I minimize those risks
like limit your exposure ten
50 million dollars I will 100% watch PB
freebasing in a basement you know you
know we're breaking bad ends that's
where peewee takes off that's where he
starts I'm the one who not that's
terrifying
that's my impression I found it
we were the Playhouse all oh no I think
I think that work should take risks I
mean come on like there's so many
different streaming platforms now
there's no reason not to do this
personally I think if he really wanted
to make this he could just Kickstarter I
mean he's no Rubens like [ __ ] like
peewee yeah people do yeah people would
want to see it
so I I like indiegogo I don't know yeah
there's a dozen ways for that guy to
make money venmo cash a cameo only fans
like and then it gets really dark do we
want to talk about yeah Universal is
remaking the thing for reasons that make
no sense to me because it was perfect
they made sequels to the thing which are
fine yeah no again why I don't know
Universal is not gonna hire me to do
anything anytime soon I mean I'm staying
out of this conversation well you know
isn't it because they found a longer
text they did apparently the the novel
the short story that the original movie
was made Howard Hawks his movie in the
30s and and then shankar murders movie
in the 80s were both based on an
original short story called
like who goes there yeah and apparently
that had been adapted by the author into
a novel that was lost to time in space
that has since been recovered and so now
they want to readapt it using the
additional text which I mean okay sure
I'll but
I I personally think that when you were
making a thing remake it in hopes that
you can make it better yeah
and I don't know the size of the window
there is to make a better version of
that movie than John Carpenter's they
said that they're gonna take the best
elements from each of them it's like the
buffet remake of like I want some of
that I knew some apprently it's like an
a MV on a YouTube do you remember those
I don't know people still do um I just
remember all the anime ones and they'd
be too like Linkin Park and they would
be or would be like pop or like cut my
life into pieces and it's just Vegeta
powering the kirk/spock slash yes yeah
closer
mm-hmm yeah that awakened things I mean
just these longing glances of [ __ ]
spock looking at Kirk and then I want to
[ __ ] you cannon that's how it works
boys and girls I think we're done with
the news which means that we move on to
the Q&A part of our show in which you
all ask questions and we give out prizes
and potentially let me see what we have
to give away today our dignity they paid
for that already this is now a bonus we
have tickets from our good friends at
40x
you ever been to a 40 X movie no oh yeah
did you feel different yes it's making
feel yeah yeah yeah just like you kind
of sit down and you're like oh I
expected not that at all my kidney
stones are gone and you feel like I'm
now a different religion but but they're
super cool so we have some sets of those
we also have in my magic bag of plenty
your Mary Poppins bag my Mary Poppins
bag I have some t-shirts from the good
folks at a loot crate
let's see if there's a he-man t-shirt a
cute cap and Bucky t-shirt Hydra dope
Hydra world tour t-shirt
and they Xavier school of the blabbity
blah t-shirt and these were these were
supposed to be Christmas presents but it
took forever what a good dad what a good
dad
and they took forever to arrive from
China because they're pretty bootleg but
yes yes like baby
Yoda shed worth it worth it worth it
worth it baby yeah I mean it's probably
made of asbestos what if you want it I
don't want it in my house so I have two
of those so we'll figure out some way to
divvy all this [ __ ] up I figured I got
four t-shirts
[Music]
maybe we have one I actually have fan
mail for you that somebody sent to me oh
my because my address is public and
yours is not so I've been trying to work
that out
what full disclosure I pre opened it to
make sure wasn't anthrax thank you it's
just cocaine yes it's Metallica that's a
dope as hell its Miles Morales
spider-man by renegade artists love it
well thank you renegade artists that's
super rad oh there's a note too what if
I can't read I'm gonna break your bar
too well in that'll make God should I do
a dramatic reading of the note
let's see hey man no that's wrong
Clarence have a big fan hello I'm a big
fan of fat man beyond feminine Batman
and oh I don't have my glasses and from
it a fan of yours as great as Kevin is
it's your switched on and sometimes most
cynical personality that gives this show
such a great chemistry no offense to the
great Kevin Smith but this is a why
black man on Batman is just as amusing
to watch and it's the two of you
together I'm an artist in Cape May New
Jersey and being that I'm an artist I
don't have the means to go on a show in
Hollywood and live this and give us to
you in person
whoever hearing you a part of the
conversation that helped create Miles
Morales I wanted to get this to you
anyway I hope you dig the painting as
much as I did creating it love always
renegade you're a wizard Harry Harry
great I don't know what impression that
was that was just a rich white guy kind
of cultured inbred but yes so questions
what you got JC
coming to the spotlight hello hey man
James James good to meet you man how are
you good the show for you work
tell use my birthday actually well as as
is our tradition we have to sing you
happy birth all right so everybody pipe
up you ready birthday to you happy
birthday to you
i Pavarotti just for you man sweet thank
you that was amazing my question is you
know what the past couple years has
always been these like arguments over is
like there's too many superhero movies
too many IP is there not enough original
ideas but then original movies come out
nobody goes to see them and that's Lance
for like this year it's like we're you
know there's the movies are people
talking about the end of the year now
more original movies and I just like
this argument it just bothers me I think
it's stupid and I think it's a guy who
loves soupier movies and I love other
movies it's just like how do you guys
think that any of that's valid still
like do you think that like I feel like
the big movies that come over this year
between Joker and endgame yet we're
still talking about like Jo Jo rabbit
and all these other in ridgeland movies
that doesn't feel like I now talked
about more I don't know you know what I
mean um do you have a feeling of it well
I think I hope that it shows the
studio's that they can take risks on
things like this but it is also I think
it's a two-way street I do I think the
more marketing they put that makes it
available for people to find these
things like whatever when I think of
like whatever gets on the front page of
Netflix there's things that come out on
Netflix all the time but if you get the
front page then you know like everyone's
sitting down that weekend is gonna see
that and that's how I was gonna say when
the Punisher wasn't on the front page I
was like oh no the second season or the
third season I was like no this is
getting cancelled it's not it just came
out
but um yeah but I also think it's a big
thing of like the audience actually
showing up like actually going out and
showing up to these indie indie movies
totally I mean I think that there there
have always been and by always I mean
since like 1978 like the big-ass [ __ ]
giant movies and then the smaller kind
of arthouse movies but there had also
always been this like wide middle of the
kind of movies that just used to get
made you know like 40 50 60 million
dollar just like [ __ ] movies what
I'm gonna go see fugitive or I'm gonna
go see presumed innocent or I'm gonna
name some other Harrison Ford movie or
I'm gonna go some romantic comedy I'm
gonna go see Silverado I'm gonna go see
go see like there used to be a lot of
different [ __ ] that was all fueled by
home video in the rental market was that
they knew they can make their money back
in home video and then once DVDs became
the thing that sold they knew they could
sell DVDs that is vanished like we've
gone from being a collector culture to a
just accessible culture you don't need
to own it anymore you just need to be
able have access to it and that makes
you happy but that has erased that
financial initiative that made Studios
make all of those kind of movies and so
yeah we're still gonna get your end
games and you know apparently there's
like nine more Transformers movies and
then there's a joker every year by law
and then we're still gonna get the same
Oscar movies that they used to make
before because they're hungry for awards
are gonna get you jo-jo rabbits and your
little woman's and your your parasites
those things are always gonna happen but
it was that like
mid-range movie that like hey this was
just like an adult murder if this was
[ __ ] you know the intern or this was
when Harry Met Sally or this was you me
and Dupree you mean to be like comedies
don't get made that much as they used to
anymore we're the good boys this year
yeah there's always like one or two I
mean but either they're micro budget
like book smart or occasion there's a
game night or a good boy but even book
smart was seen as not doing well you
know and so I think that's that's what
we're missing and I think that's what
people are beginning to feel that they
don't have anymore and that's where
Netflix is beginning to step in and yeah
oh we'll do the Irishman we know you
don't want to do the Irishman for
reasons that don't make sense because
you don't think adults will go to the
movies to see like the adventures of old
Italian mobsters it turns out that they
would have gone if you gave it to them
and I think that it's just it's shifting
and it's changing and the things we get
to see in the movies are not the things
we used to get all the time in the
movies and so now it just be like III
introduced a screening of pitch black at
the Alamo Drafthouse and I was kind of
and one of the things we talked about
was the fact if that was a movie that
cost 32 million dollars that was based
on nothing but a really good script and
you couldn't do that
today you literally could not pry thirty
million dollars from a studio to just
make an original thing unless you then
stocked it with like Inception like we
got [ __ ] leader Caprio and we got
Christopher Nolan and they want to make
this movie we're not gonna say no
because we want one of them to make
another Batman movie for us it's harder
to get that done that it used to be and
that's where I'm beginning to feel a
little bit of like oh man we used to do
that remember like district 9 wasn't an
anomaly it just kind of happened a lot
member you just got like a Robocop and
that was super cool and we're not
getting that anymore so that's I don't
think it's good or bad I mean because I
think the business is shifting as it
always does but I think I'm mindful of
the fact of the things that we're not
getting as much as we used to where we
used to get them happy birthday man
not come and get some [ __ ] James Mays
prizes man you come back to New York
kick ass all right
let's see which t-shirt would you like
that's that's the benefit of asking the
first question you get the best pick of
t-shirts and that's Hydra X Man X minute
some tickets
thanks man take it easy hey man what's
your name hi guys I'm Ben I'm from
Australia oh I think okay you might have
one day I think you've one day I came
farthest for this show I assume Kevin
keV you're looking great thank you
the roads been good to you keV big
latina yes he's been trying to do that
for years down didn't have latina
I wanted to mention one thing about the
mandalorian as well when Carl Weathers
come in do we not just want to see like
Carl Weathers and the mandalorian do the
big hands on hand and Arnold
Schwarzenegger did from the predator hey
you just see to see Carl and amanda
Lauren hey Amanda
the getting weak man huh see I got you
pushing too many pencils but one of my
favorite things from the show is usually
when care books to you guys I want that
script I'd like to hear you've got low
key
you've got wonder wonder vision and was
a captain and talking and went to
something in the air
can we hear one on one script anything
from you just something that you would
think you'd like to see from those okay
an episode of those shows or like just
one like if I could pick any comic book
any one of those three series of the
coming out what information that we've
got so far is very very small okay hmm I
think I think Loki's gonna give you the
most bang for your buck like you've got
to just pick one of those shows to make
an episode out of given that he's got
the tesseract and he cannot travel
through time again I feel like you kind
of want to see Loki [ __ ] some [ __ ] up in
a big bad way like I think you want to
see him
I mean the thing they could do which be
kind of awesome is if he's responsible
for the capsule accident that creates
the Fantastic Four like like if he is if
he is in that sure thing I can I'm just
BAM see it's like I need more particles
whatever it just sucks a little bit from
that [ __ ] capsule when they go to
outer space and [ __ ] goes wrong it's
like oh I didn't mean to do that I was
just trying to kill some kids in my
basement and I created another super
team oh yeah I mean they're gonna try
and find a way to introduce offenders
and for at some point and I think Loki
Loki lets you do a lot of the things you
might want to do without being bound by
continuity that much and just change
[ __ ] you [ __ ] it up in a good way Loki
they might do that they might do that do
you look I
I love that your thing is so thought out
and I was like I just want to see him
dating I would like to see Loki I'm like
a pro yeah he's gonna be a bachelors
bachelors rose for you
oh my gosh but I just want to see his
his his downtime yeah does Loki have
game
yeah or is it just all magic in she dies
playing PlayStation I know does he is he
the guy that's like I'm I'm 611 or
whatever in his profile mm-hmm his
picture is like him and a dog even
though he doesn't own it his roommates
dog totally this look didn't happen to
me like I really love puppies
I love genocide long walks in the park
especially after the genocide I want to
see his like illegitimate kid that just
like shows up one day at his work dad
it's me Kevin Kevin Loki son kanpai some
child support
have you seen elf that's basically what
I want I want that would be [ __ ]
awesome the Loki Christmas special yes a
very Disney Christmas yeah thank you
very much thank you
when do you head back to Australia okay
all right well then take some [ __ ] I
will say take a baby Yoda he wants a
movie tickets so you're not gonna be
able to hit the movies I need to pitch
my wan division script what you got they
end up in 1980s San Francisco late 80s
early 90s in the Tanner household
yes and you have elizabeth Olsen meeting
her Little Big Sisters because in the
trailer she's like in the Brady Bunch
house and Leave It to Beaver put her in
the [ __ ] full house house please nice
good Paul Loki is Uncle Jesse
thank you very much I think okay before
you ask your question Andy yeah we are
going to now it becomes a sort of
applause-o-meter for the baby Yoda Yoda
left I'm still in town for the weeks I'm
just saying maybe I was gonna get to go
to the best okay it's a child to be
honest we don't know it's baby yodel
it's not no you know put the wagon you
know hitch the wagon so okay I'm sorry
Jon Favreau what you got man so this is
one pitch and jumping off of writing our
scripts and stuff crisis on Infinite
Earths finally introduce the possibility
of your Green Lantern you know they
hinted and stuff I've been dying for it
like I love Green Lantern because for me
it is the one hero that you have to have
strong will doesn't matter where you're
from you just have to be right you know
and for me growing up Jon Stewart is
Green Lantern you know I mean I like you
know it's more than just it they defy
you don't have to be in front of space
you don't be an orphan with the billion
dollars you don't be anything so I
really like that idea so my question is
this if we were to do Green Lantern and
this goes for both of you because I've
always pictured Denzel playing Jon
Stewart mm-hmm and and that and and if
we did a female version Salma Hayek I'm
sorry I'm a real like big from dusk till
dawn fan you know her but she could it
in reality all you need is goodwill
right so like why not so from both of
you if we could pitch a Green Lantern
script genders doesn't matter race
doesn't matter whatever if we could do
it well who would you pick and who would
you have as a villain because yeah
movies only as good as the counterpart
to it right I'm afraid that I'm still
caught on some a Hayek playing Green
Lantern oh I know she'd kill it though I
mean on it for like every good reason
oh and she has to have the frito callow
you know the unibrow yeah well I think
if I'm if I'm not mistaken Lamont didn't
they didn't yeah then they toss up I'm
sorry
Lamont my friend and the corner he's
trying to run away he works on Black
Lightning and was kind of involved that
[ __ ] now I did not see the finale of
arrow but I have it on good authority
from people who did see it that John
Diggle is Green Lantern III from the
beginning thought it was him
yeah so well yeah because they have that
scene where they're like oh where's your
ring I caught that yeah and it's all
like glowy green but also the HBO max
announced a Green Lantern - I don't know
if that's new I mean that was literally
in the news but right but if I had my
dream Green Lantern yes no and Andrus
elbows off the table
okay can I cast him time nonspecific you
can guess him whatever okay but it cuz
now I was like hey Jim Brown I think you
might make it [ __ ] awesome Green
Lantern Robert Redford Robert all right
but which Lantern is here we just
thought like Billy Billy the lantern no
no no [ __ ] yeah like we'll pretend
that he is just he's he's Green Lantern
like like I've always liked the idea
what Chris Nolan did like you don't have
to start with a heavy like I'd like for
the first Green Lantern outing to be
like the Manhunters like just you know
throwaway character and then lead up to
something bigger you know so who would
you put it villain if Robert Redford was
fighting you know who would be fighting
Owen Wilson
whoa I mean I I would want to keep it on
earth I think you keep it you keep it
grounded one of one of my rebel Wilson
rub it in Owen Wilson all the Wilsons
Rita Wilson the [ __ ] ball the Wilson
Tom Hanks Wilson's volleyball yeah I
think you keep it on earth because I
remember when I saw the movie like I've
never been the biggest Green Lantern fan
but I remember seeing the movie and my
son who was done like seven goes so
there's a lot of Green Lantern's and I
said yeah buddy
and and he's not even like the best one
yeah that's right
so so why is this movie about in and I
said I don't know like that's fair point
it's a giant [ __ ] space cop movie and
there's a lot of cops that are better at
this and like gooder than he is and so I
think you want to keep it about Green
Lantern as the one Green Lantern and
keep it on earth I think you're bad guys
[ __ ] Lobo man my fan fiction um you
know I don't I kind of wish that they
had I hope that they do it's whatever
series that it's like someone that's
maybe undiscovered because I feel like I
know Lamonica Garrett tweeted because
someone was like oh there's a new Green
Lantern over at this and he was like I
mean he did like the eyes like the I am
but also I feel like for Jon Stewart I
could also see because now his show
isn't around but Mike Colter now that
he's not Luke Cage but that's what I
mean and I'm like you already got your
superhero but here you go again
you're so good we like you see shiny
yeah and all the right shows so funny
somebody had a tweet and it was like was
when Luke Cage was area and it was like
the wildest thing that's going on here
is that this man would work at a
barbershop and not be a male model
he's just so hot like a gigolo
yes least amount of hair and works at
birdie shop kind of weird luke cage's
only fans sweet Christmas so yes so I
think there's like men that order people
that come to mind when it comes to John
Stewart but I also do kind of think it
would be great to cast someone that's
like up and coming in and give them a
new platform to be a superhero
Nick Cannon yeah we're not doing Green
Lantern College right like [ __ ] Nick
Cannon there we go sorry yeah so yeah
that my pick is is Redford against Lobo
played by Jason Momoa because of course
he should be lobo and you are going for
an unknown brand new person do you have
a bad guy in mind for Lobo
I always thought that was Joe bagging
Alec he always ran guys no for me okay
all right he literally played a wolf
like in True Blood yeah yeah and I can
see that I was looking for more like I
think there's a dirty hot to Momoa but I
don't know if Megan Ella can summon then
again I didn't see much of True Blood so
I don't know how dirty hot he can be oh
he can be dirty uh yet him I don't know
whoo-hoo-hoo they're very
interchangeable Rob Gronkowski there you
go Tom Brady anyone does that answer
question Nick Lachey yes
it's all yours man thank you would you
like more tell the people what your name
is I'm autumn like
season and actually in the injustice to
mobile game Jon Stewart kind of looks
like marshal Ali so I would be kind of
down for that because if you play the
game it looks very much like him so I
mean he's bleeding that could be like a
star-making one but it'd be cool to see
him in that kind of role yes my question
is relates to anime since you like enemy
and I know you've been watching Dragon
Prince no you should watch it is it on
Netflix yeah yeah three seasons half an
hour long each episode I blazed through
it in like eight days so good I did that
with this circle and I feel really bad
about myself I watched in 24 hours it
was not help yeah but I follow shoe bomb
who's one of the I don't know if you
guys know shooby anyways I'm the only
circle fan in here it's moving on it's
like Big Brother but okay worse but yes
move into the square you go back to your
normal life they get $100,000 yeah
300,000 followers on Instagram or
whatever from this one show that they
did it's wild and I'm jealous there's no
great British making show well you know
what they win a great big show a [ __ ]
plate everyone talked about the show
forever and I finally sat down and
watched it during Christmas and they
like cooked this magnificent meal and I
was like holy crap and then they're like
and you're next thing and I'm like what
let these people sit oh I would be
exhausted I would be like I'm done for
the day this is this is abusive there's
an attempt all weekend long baking all
kinds of [ __ ] it's not going no money
and no say in who eat it
he's just [ __ ] scarfing like a madman
given kind of the surge of anime
becoming even more popular and live one
yeah good but given a popularity which
one would you pull I would say you could
do new ones like a dragon Prince like
one piece but something a classic one
like an older one and what would you do
with that now like if you could do it as
a TV series as a movie life action and
how like how would you go about it okay
listen this is my thing no take it glow
but instead Sailor Moon
I can say that it's like a tease Sailor
Moon right Jupiter like you let go back
hmm
their schooldays but like Sailor Moon Oh
be so amazing oh my gosh they did
actually deal with a lot of stuff I
don't know if you've watched it but it
like they you know would deal with like
dating and Tuxedo Mask being a [ __ ] boy
up to update he would be a luchador yes
and then all of a sudden it's like here
comes the white knight and I think that
they're going to do Sailor Moon I mean
it's such a huge franchise I know that
they have iterations of it live action
but I think over here I think that that
would be a great series I think that
could be a great television series cuz
they started booting it again and sort
of re-airing but also the new one I
haven't seen a new one there's many
iterations of yes there's many
iterations okay I'm of two minds okay
the first mind is ridiculous but I would
do I would do the lions Voltron version
because I [ __ ] love the lines the
lines is my jam as a kid
yeah makes no sense no like why do you
build liens why not just [ __ ] people
why why do they have to then become a
giant person which you know you're gonna
do anyway so just make the [ __ ] giant
person why we got to do this [ __ ] or
like I don't know where's what happened
to the pink line but I still think it's
so [ __ ] rad I just I love the design
it's so silly that you embrace it and
then it becomes awesome or samurai
champloo oh especially with the hip-hop
like yeah I think I think sort of marry
about you know period in Japan and so I
can like Ronin to run around with a
badass [ __ ] hip-hop score and just
doing period but with a total modern
sensibility it becomes Hamilton with
swords in a way that could be awesome
The Bachelor but with Tenchi Muyo
[Music]
there's a lot of hot babes directly to
Netflix I'm just trying to keep up
I literally work for them I'm so good so
those are people a writer
[Laughter]
edit this I know I also like I know it's
dumb but in a post cat's world
Thundercats yeah there's some franchises
that I'm like whether you like it or not
they're gonna be made live-action mmm
there's just too much money too much
nostalgia and like Thundercats would be
so [ __ ] problematic at this this is
an anime but the scariest thing I want
to see you live action is Hey Arnold
[Laughter]
because I can't look if they could do
the Irishman they could do a Arnold
[Laughter]
okay Jen before this gets any worse yes
your question yes great would do project
Aiko added okay Marvel Universe that's a
joke because she is the kid of
superheroes like Superman and Wonder
Woman so I would see something like that
of the next generation okay Netflix just
give you money okay thank you
hey watch Leah Leah it's good good to
meet you what's your question I first I
just wanted to say I've been listening
to the podcast it's it was Kevin talking
to Paul Dini in his closet and this show
is so great since you came on I think
it's great that you're going on your own
I think you had we loved the show when
it started as Kevin because he loves
everything or he only talks about the
stuff that he loves and he talks about
the things he loves and stuff even they
didn't love all of the stuff that movie
Superman and but you even though people
criticize you for being critical you
come from a place of love you enjoy
things just like him you just don't not
an apologist for things you know and I
have that critical lens really adds so
much to like chewing in and dissecting
and responding in the film's I really
appreciate it well thank you very much
that's super caelum I always I always I
come at this stuff like it's okay we
love things not for their perfections
but for their flaws and some
acknowledging of the reasons why they're
flawed helps us love it more great
unless it's you know Superman and for
the opportunities they give us for the
next iteration like comic books there's
always gonna be another iteration of
this IP so my question is to do with
that in the age of the consolidation of
IP and to these mega franchises this
mega holders of different IP how likely
or unlikely do you think it is that
we're going to get a main character that
is queer
and I don't mean a villain I mean a main
character or a main you know supporting
character who is like not you know
sister straight in any of these mega
franchises Marvel etc it took Marvel 18
films to not have a white man as the
main character to give his Black Panther
took us 20 films to get a female main
character I think it's gonna take even
longer to get anything other than that
so I'm hopeful Kevin Feige said of
Marvel at least that we're going to get
some representation but I don't know
what that means you know and I think
you're probably as cynical as I am but
you probably have a slightly inner more
nuanced view and I'm interested in your
point of you also I I too AM cynical but
if there is one thing that I think you
can trust in Hollywood is that they will
chase money where they see it hanging on
trees for them and if Black Panther and
Wonder Woman has taught them anything
it's that underserved audiences will
over perform and over represent in the
box office because the it's it's water
in the desert like I've never seen this
so I will go see it nine times to make
sure I get to see it again and I think
they know that now and I think that they
understand that there is a huge LGBTQIA
audience out there that's waiting for
this and if it comes to them they will
support it like nobody's [ __ ]
business and that's money on the table
for them I mean creatively not even
talking about that spiritually not even
talking about that purely mercenary the
way Hollywood works is they will go to
where the money is and there's money
here so I think that it will happen 100%
when it happens I don't know I think
sooner rather than later
hmm honestly because I think they're
reading those tea leaves as anybody else
is and they're beginning to realize the
the over performance of movies like that
I remember when then they were first
starting to track the box office
predictions for Black Panther and it
started it like 110 million dollars
opening weekend that's amazing then it
went to like hundred forty million
dollars opening weekend this was like a
couple weeks out then I went to like
hundred sixty million and then it showed
it like 210 million
opening weekend it's a hundred million
dollar gap between what they thought it
was gonna be and what it actually was
hmm and that is because they didn't
understand that audience which is again
you gave me a thing I've always wanted
I'm gonna come and show out for that
what in the desert totally so I think
that that that is what will get that
kind of representation on screen is pure
economic greed which is the one thing
you can always count on hmm I did want
to say though Black Lightning and The CW
has been like really reppin queer
characters like just openly gay just
openly as they all should be and I feel
like there actually are at least the
actors of a lot of in these franchises
have kind of hinted at like oh no my
character is queer but I understand what
you're saying is like and can we see
that though you know because of course
there's like a ton of queerbaiting and
like a lot of this stuff and I agree
with you I think that I I think it's
time that we have the main title
character it's just so weird that these
take place in it's how I felt about Game
of Thrones which like this is just gonna
be a tiny ramp but it was just like yeah
but you know like during that time there
wasn't really you know people of color
like what time the dragon time that
doesn't make sense like if we could have
a dragon you can have a black person
like it just you know and so that's how
I feel about some of these and then it's
like people that have kind of and
they're changing but it's an audience
that is like so angrily held onto things
and what we talked about when you were
even on my show is they'll be like well
that's not the source material and it's
like look we weren't allowed in the
source material like we weren't allowed
to be in a lot of these comics that
started back in the 40s and the 50s and
now it needs to be reflect it should
have oh we always existed we were always
here you know but now it's like more
than ever it should be reflective it
doesn't make sense you know if you can
shoot fireballs you can have a bi person
like I think there's and there's ways to
do it
like if I'm Marvel I make Loki pansexual
because duh like clearly that character
would be and he is in the comics yeah
like and he's moved past being a villain
like he's no longer the big bad anymore
he's now the protagonist of his own TV
show which again front and center and he
has even in the film's in Ragnarok you
know and in in in infinity war like
reclaimed his sense of honor and heroism
to the point where like yeah yeah well
wouldn't you do that he could do that
cost you nothing to do that and the
people who are going to show for Loki
which of course they will will be like
oh yeah that guy Quicksilver Tom
everybody likes one of those why
wouldn't he be and I think that this
kind of way Donald Glover was saying
about Lando yeah like that dude [ __ ]
every yeah yeah
equal opportunity everyone want seven
robots ships like that dude will mount
up for whatever comes to their yeah he's
there for it like he's got a giant
[ __ ] cape barren in the back of his
like I think that we're going to get it
in ways that won't feel quite as showy
as here's our first gay hero and more
like a oh this is the thing that's been
hiding in plain sight that you've seen
all along and by making it that kind of
Trojan horse you will get an audience
who would avoid it to become enraptured
by it and forced to come and see it and
and I and I do love that about kind of
the way modern media seems to be working
which is let me charge and horse a thing
you don't want anything we know you're
gonna love yeah watch man was that
Watchmen was let me Trojan horse a very
trenchant look at black pain in America
inside a superhero drama that absolutely
people who would not have tuned in for a
trench and look at black pain in America
would tune in because I think dr.
Manhattan's gonna be here right wait
he's a black dude what you know I mean
black paired to do that you had to see
black panther if you were Marvel fan
whether or not you would have ever
showed up for that if it's not black
panther you were gonna come Wonder Woman
you had to go [ __ ] see that we built
an audience that will show up for this
stuff and now giving them a thing they
didn't think they were gonna like and
turns out that they love is sort of a
great innovation of like
late teens in the early aughts of your
gonna dig it you have no choice does
that answer things hopefully alright
this is our last set of tickets and you
can pick a t-shirt if you would like why
also how easy would a valkyrie movie be
to sell or a miniseries
right I'm like yeah no-brainer
no-brainer
alright we got one more question one
more set of tickets we were hiding but
now [ __ ] it let's put it out there [ __ ]
it why not
[ __ ] it women hello hi how's it going
I'm a degenerate so I feel at home could
be worse right in every way I could've
been watching the State of the Union and
I wasn't because I'm hard with nerds
so that was an awesome question and that
was a really good segue into what I was
going to ask so well actually first of
all I loved you guys both on the crisis
aftermath there was a really dope
dynamic you guys had done it for all of
the episodes or at least like a wrap-up
one so yeah let's do it again do it
again
yeah please okay never mind they have
the Hall of Justice now so they got it
right I know I don't put some [ __ ] in
there look like an empty Pier one
Imports just one table it's a little
creepy okay so something I've been
thinking about a lot recently and would
love to get your guys's take on is we've
had you know we've had Wonder Woman
we've had Captain Marvel we've had Black
Widow who would you want to see as the
first woman of color to helm one of
those big IP movies it doesn't
necessarily have to be DC or marvel but
like one that's gonna be on that scale
and how would you if we haven't already
met her how would you sort of bring her
into how would you intro her I got one
okay I I think I think there's a way to
do a story about a young thief
who's sort of like living this
hardscrabble life and has had the worst
[ __ ] like fate Ascended are the worst
and at every turn until it turns out
that she can make it rain you know I
think I think you could absolutely do a
storm movie I think that it seems as if
it's it's an early in the kind of x-men
run because you know they're gonna do
one of those for everybody but to like
come in early and come in on that story
and orient us in that version of the
real world which will inform how she
treats everybody the Xavier mansion when
she gets there because she has always
gotten the shortest shrift in any of
those movies she's just like literally
color on the borders and I think that to
Center that story to Center sort of like
child endangerment and and refugees and
all of that [ __ ] but make it about an ex
person whatever they're gonna call that
franchise I think would be kind of fun
and I think we get we get Barry Jenkins
to make this movie I think why would ya
[ __ ] it like let's aim for the stars if
we're gonna do it I'm okay
wait I did have a good idea okay so so
maybe you know Peter Parker has to
graduate eventually I know this is 2023
and he's playing 16 that's fine I love
you Tom Holland but I would love to see
him in his college years and at his
college he runs into a college-age girl
named America Chavez was also in college
and you know has to save the world and
also do college things as you do
ripping bong hits you know she's a
tri-delt
I would love you know I think that they
are gonna introduce America Chavez into
the Disney Plus series however a lot of
those are inter lapping and I really do
think that she can have her own movie
and I think the Latin X community will
show up for it as we do we were there
for Dora
we got the woman we love to have more we
would love to have more um so and I
think it needs to be done well as they
all do but like that's how I feel about
a lot of like another things that we
didn't say about Black Panthers that it
had to do well right like there's always
this this we don't get the second chance
we don't get the you know so I would
love for it to be lovingly made by
someone that I don't know I'm trying to
think who I'd want that but yeah I think
there could be a college college yeah
yeah he could do it said Robert
Rodriguez
I would love a woman email yeah but when
I think of my friend Gloria Calderon
Kellet who's in comedy and she's also a
director and I think that that would be
great to have a comedic you know I feel
like I love the Marvel films that live
in that world like spider-man so I would
love to see America Chavez comedy
college-aged I've already pitched it
thank you
Marvel yeah you should I think Alfonso
korone would be interested oh my gosh
just because my favorite movie of his is
Harry Potter movie and it's about kids
like it's about the sort of rambunctious
and so children living in this magical
world in which there are rules they'd
want to break all the time and it's and
that that entire that gave life to that
series it would have been dead in the
water if you don't have somebody to just
find a way to pull it out of these
[ __ ] robes and these crazy like
static buildings and actually give
everything the sense of life which is
the thing that he does really well I
think he'd be if you had to start making
a list in Oscar Isaacs her professor I
mean come on
[Music]
Dean's Pedro Pascal I mean listen we're
just not casting your fantasy girl is
like Salma Hayek's one of her mom's I
mean I've already done it I don't care
if anybody goes to see this you just
need to make this movie
her fairy godmothers Jennifer Lopez it's
like we're already there or Rita Moreno
yes oh my gosh
well then Gloria has to direct it but
I'm seen and done um I would watch both
of those movies I was also thinking
about storm but I was thinking so
there's some versions of it where she's
actually from Wakanda and she's a love
interest for T'Challa but what if she
ends up being a love interest for Sheree
when Sheree becomes Black Panther and
then she gets like a feat off from that
sure he's another person that I think
could have her own film like I would
also be queer yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
part of me wants to keep like I was I
appreciated what they did when they made
they find a way to unite Black Panther
and storm in the comic books but the
same token it's like so the only two
black people in since higher universe
have to get married because they don't
know anybody else like couldn't she just
have her own thing and he has his own
thing and like they meet at the club I
was like hey what up and that's it but
also what Condon in the 90s animated
series right it wasn't just that right
there's tenuous threads that do make
sense but it was always like no I get it
but no that's a great question thank you
come and get some yeah well you can have
the shirt for sure and then we'll do the
quick poll for who gets the last
[ __ ] black market baby
you actually just Kermit the Frog just
like a muppet baby it's leftovers it's
leftover Spaceballs merch that's just
old Mel Brooks doll so who do we think
who do we think gets the magic Yoda book
doll we just had that last question we
had autumns question about anime
live-action we had first LGBTQIA hero
center of it oh my gosh there was one
more in there that I can remember
are people voting are we voting applause
okay
so round of applause and we'll test the
meter who should be our Green Lantern
yeah you're not going to da man he
didn't really okay so Jay James for his
birthday
[Applause]
live-action anime I appreciated a female
Marvel hero or DC here to get her own
spotlight movie and an LGBTQ centered in
in a drama okay
I've been swayed fourth birthday I'm
easily bar James only happens once a
year every single year I know
happy birthday James happy birthday Man
Alive
that is an episode of black man Beyond
if you guys had fun tonight
[Applause]
well this particular podcast does not
exist without the person to my right
where can people find you in the world
Danny Fernando I'm at Miz Danny
Fernandez it's MS da ni fer and and easy
and if you follow me you can see all my
show announcements and every time I'm on
a podcast or doing something live or at
Comic Con and yeah I I cannot thank you
enough for giving me your Tuesday night
on the heels of what sounded like a
marathon couple of days at work so yes
it means the world to me thank you for
coming to play with me behind a bar in
Hollywood Thanks
thank you I just all I wanted to do is
pitch my Batman cap man that's it that's
why I came I got the script in my trunk
you know I feel like I'm glad that we
were able to make that dream come you're
gonna laugh and then you'll see cat man
announcing it'll be like she did it
no she did it go mend it into the world
we are not back next Tuesday but we were
back on the 18th for the last black man
beyond of this particular run Carrie
Peyton is going to be my special guest
host king is Akhil Ezequiel from from
Walking Dead
voice of cyborg and a thousand versions
of Justice League but yeah he's gonna
hold it down with me you know do a less
good job but whatever he also a thick
latina I've listened I've seen his ass
not gonna say why he is not I fear that
this will be the last of the [ __ ] latina
run but you held it down thank you so
yes tickets for that will go on sale
shortly until then we will be back same
black time same black channel
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith SModcast
comm all the things thank you for coming
everybody get home safe
[Music]
you
[Music]
you